What does it mean to
be a Queen?
I work hard in every aspect of my life,
in my career, on my body, in my spirit
and I deserve somebody who mirrors that.
If that's a Queen, then I need a Prince.
Do I need a King?
I'm someone who has
the addictive
personality trait.
I can attach myself
to anything
and overdo it.
It's destructive.
I've been a bit reckless.
I'm learning to
unlearn things.
That's taken a lot of
work on my end
because I didn't realize I was the chaos.
In the past, I used to do things to seek approval.
What would they think about this or that?
I'm not there anymore.
I'm afraid of people.
New people like to hurt you.
It's really hard for me to let my guard down,
but it's time to kinda,
take the bricks down.
As individual women,
all of us have experienced
a lot of the same trauma,
verbal abuse,
domestic violence,
very public relationships.
It's a lot.
I'm like, am cursed? Am I hexed?
Why do they always end up like this?
How did he make you feel?
My p***y wasn't twingling.
Mine was to death.
It was river dancing.
You can't come over here
trying to be funny when I'm just chilling.
You smell me?
Ooh, red flag.
So is this a problem, me
standing this close to you?
No. You should back up.
You should back up.
You're gonna have
to pray for us.
So that door is open.
Oh, that door is wide open.
Ohh!
I'm starting to feel like a little P-I-M-P around here.
It's not gonna take nothing
for this man to
get my vagina.
You like nipple clamps, sis?
I'm open to it.
Because we've been through, like, so much,
when someone is so nice to you...
Thank you.
...I have to tell myself it's
okay to be treated this way.
It is not going to be easy
to become a King to one of our Queens.
The question is...
are you the man they're looking for?
I just don't know
if he's genuine.
I don't want to have a conversation about it.
Because who you
got your eyes on
may not have
their eyes on you.
Oh!!
I think you’ve
had plenty of time
and I would like for you to go pack your bags
and leave the house tonight.
Well, that's said and done.
You are...
not our King.
We need someone
who knows
how to treat a Queen.
I want it to be the real thing.
All these years,
I haven't been chasing love.
I feel like a team.
Will you marry me?